ouais alors vanessa vous êtes né en 1972
à saint-maur-des-fossés votre père andré
était président directeur général d'une
miroiterie oui joliment guinée d'une
miroiterie ces zélés et poutres en
polyuréthane abondamment et avec des
miroirs dont je vais [ __ ] apparente en
polyuréthane et votre mère corinne était
directrice de la société c'est ça a été
je vais une pompe comptable dans la
société
les parents très uni non je dis ça parce
que celui des parents très uni 30 ans
que ça vous sert de modèle vous pour
monter numéro à trévoux dès l'âge de 4
ans pour les cours de piano et de danse
rythmique vous monter des petits
spectacles est alors un jour votre oncle
le comédien didier pain remarque que
votre joli brin de voix et vous propose
enfin propose à vos parents que vous
fassiez l'école des femmes
voilà votre première apparition à la
télévision c'est plus que ça c'est mon
oncle et il sait que je rêve de chanter
que les comédies musicales c'est tout ce
qui me fait rêver et et que comme les
enfants de à l'époque de mon âge regarde
l école des fans et et j'adorais la
comédie musicale emilie jolie et se
trouve qu'ils avaient une chapelle qui
faisait l'émission est né mais c'était
pas le n'était pas producteur avec moi
que c'était pour faire plaisir à
l'époque où dix huit ans et qu'on lui
dise en fait un 45 tours en association
avec les forbans qui s'appelle la magie
des surprises parties
tous ces faits interviennent troupes us
moi je vais chercher je ne trouve pas
c'est un collector si quelqu'un là
pourquoi vous voulez plus puissante
parce que je n'aime pas beaucoup et se
trouve que je l'avais enregistré à 10
ans et quand j'avais 13 ans il était
toujours pas sortir entre 10 et 20 ans
la voix le chant suis surtout les les
goûts et les envies changent donc
j'avais plus envie de faire ça puis le
disque est jamais sorti et puis au
moment où joe le taxi est sorti là comme
par hasard il est en tous les cas à
vanessa c'est grâce à cette chanson que
vous rencontrez frankland bluff lors de
l'enregistrement de la maquette de
l'album de sophie marceau c'est ça non
j'étais allé pour voir que vous la voyez
chanter dans le studio derrière la vitre
qui vous dit quand même c'est pas
terrible dit pourquoi pas moi quand vous
l'avez en plus je suis allé à l'époque
au studio parce que j'adorais ce film à
l'époque
et puis et puis j'ai rencontré franck
langolff etienne roda-gil cette époque
là et c'est vrai que je leur ai dit
j'aurais demandé de m'écrire